. There's been a super interesting turn of
events in the last 48 hours or so where Donald
Trump has called Fox News fake news at a recent
event.
And after day one of the DNC, multiple Fox
News anchors actually heaped praise upon Michelle
Obama for her speech, which was a good speech.
So let's not read into this more than what
it is.
But I do think there's an interesting discussion
here.
Here's Donald Trump in Wisconsin this week
calling Fox News fake news.
But we're doing great.
Coming back, we're coming back.
And our numbers are better than almost all
countries.
I will tell you that despite what you hear.
Look at all of them up there, Scott.
Look at all of that fake news.
It's unbelievable.
Unfortunately, Fox has become vague.
Still, I don't know what happens to these
people.
Right.
You agree.
And then continuing the reversals behavior
that is opposite what we would expect.
What we've come to expect on Monday night.
Check out Dana Perino, Chris Wallace.
People liked Michelle Obama's speech on Fox
News over the course of the night, the first
virtual convention of our history.
I think they would say that Michelle Obama
stuck the landing.
Chris Wallace, your thought.
Well, I agree with Dana.
You know, it's interesting, Michelle Obama,
as she said, doesn't like politics.
And she said that this speech was her main
contribution to the Biden campaign.
It was a heck of a contribution.
She really slayed, sliced and diced Donald
Trump talking about the chaos and confusion
and lack of empathy, especially coming from
this president and from this White House,
spoke more about the deficits of Donald Trump
than the pluses of Joe Biden.
But didn't talk about especially on some of
his policies.
But especially his empathy, what he's been
through and his care for average American
troops that we have to vote.
So what do we make of this?
Is this some major reversal where Fox News
is no longer right wing and no longer supporting
Trump and Fox News now supports Democrats?
No, no, no, no, no, not not even in the slightest.
It's a very instructive example to understand
a little bit about how corporate media works
in the United States.
Fox News offers theatrics and hyperbole from
a right wing perspective for profit.
And the for profit part is a big piece of
the analysis.
So think back to early in the 2016 Republican
primary, which started in 2015.
Really, the role of Fox News was we covered
Trump being kooky, but we oppose him because
we're a serious right wing network and we
support people like, you know, whoever the
buttoned up right winger was at the time.
Was it jab or was it, you know, Ted Cruz or
whatever?
Doesn't matter.
Trump then wins the primary, then FOX News
falls in line and gets behind Donald Trump
because they're not going to get behind Hillary
Clinton.
Hillary's bad.
Obama's bad.
They get behind Trump.
And it is a business decision fundamentally
and a decision about if Trump is president.
I mean, he's the nominee.
If he's president, we want access to Trump.
Trump becomes president and is completely
outrageous as president.
So Fox News actually sort of does a Dr. Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde sort of thing.
The opinion people remain solidly behind Trump
carrying water for him.
You know, Sean Hannity, Jeanine Pirro, Laura
Ingraham, Tucker Carlson, mostly the Fox and
Friends, people who I know that's supposedly
a news show.
Come on, guys.
That's an opinion show.
But they do want to gin up controversy and
kind of play all sides.
So when Shep Smith still worked at the network,
he would sometimes call out Trump for his
obvious lies or Chris Wallace will confront
Trump during interviews or whatever the case
may be.
OK, now we find ourselves in a situation where
it's unclear if Donald Trump is going to win.
So Fox is running parallel narratives, again,
for profit.
This is what explains the entire sort of status
quo at Fox News, Hannity and the opinion.
People are mostly still behind Trump.
If Trump wins, Trump will still be there for
them and they'll be there for Trump if Donald
Trump is reelected.
If Trump loses, Fox is laying out a little
bit of the groundwork.
They're laying a little pipe, so to speak,
to say we're objective.
We criticize Trump or praised Democrats like
Michelle Obama's speech when it made sense.
And the point is to be positioned after November
for any eventuality to maintain access to
people in positions of power.
Period.
Now, you might be wondering, does do Fox executives
pull Chris Wallace aside and go, listen, Chris,
we need you to praise Michelle Obama and really
be tough on Trump so that we can do this plan?
No, that's not the way it works.
It's much the same way as, you know, our TV
anchors will often say, I actually haven't
seen Archie in years, but years ago, I don't
even know if it's still on TV in the U.S.,
honestly.
But but years ago, Archie anchors would say,
I've never been told what to say on the air
in terms of Russia narratives or whatever.
That's not the way it works.
Right.
You are selected because you have been hired
in a role.
Right.
You you are choosing the people that on their
own will play the roles that you are trying
to fill.
And it's much the same thing on Fox News.
So I don't believe it's calculated in that
Chris Wallace needs to be told what to do.
Chris Wallace just needs to be put in positions
to do what Chris Wallace does, and that's
how they build the narrative.
So the bottom line is money.
That's really it.
The Murdoch family isn't stupid.
The big goal is to be in line with conservative
governments.
Be friendly with right wing governments around
the world.
If they can help the right retain its power,
then they will swing some support to whoever
is likely to win.
And that's the strategy.
If it looks like the right will lose power,
then they will put a little bit of support
just enough behind whoever is likely to win.
So that when that person wins, be it Joe Biden.
Or were it Hillary Clinton in 2016?
They can maintain access and they can kind
of create a responsibility from the winner
to still treat Fox News seriously, because
that's how Fox News continues to sort of replicate
itself and perpetuate itself.
This is business one to one.
You might notice there is no journalism analysis
here.
This is not a communications analysis where
you would understand, you know, in a in a
theoretical academic communication class about
anything related to journalism or media.
This is business.
This is what you would learn in business school.
And if you try to evaluate this as journalism.
The commentary makes no sense.
If you see this through the lens of business,
then it makes perfect sense.
And that's exactly what this is for Fox News.
Don't be tricked into thinking that it's anything
else.
We'll have more coverage of this on the show's
Instagram The David Pakman Show on Instagram.
And while you're there, you can follow me
on Instagram at David Dot
Packman as well.